it takes many hands on deck to land the
week's catch UK waters are teeming with
opportunities but there aren't enough
British workers to crew the boats and
process the produce we've had problems
trying to recruit young people into the
industry for a while it just doesn't
seem to be a job that young people are
wanting to do anymore unfortunately
we've been setting up apprenticeships
and and trying to get young people in
that way but it's it's still not working
in terms of homegrown talents the
government's responded to the labor
crisis in the fishing industry by
quietly agreeing to allow more foreign
workers into the country despite touting
control over immigration as a main
reason for leaving the EU in fact three
years after brexit UK net migration has
never been higher
the problem is they just simply Aren't
Enough British workers willing to labor
in dangerous not in cramped conditions
and also the tight profit margins mean
that wages can be extremely
unpredictable now under a new government
scheme they're allowing employers to
hire many more foreign workers paying
them potentially substantially less than
local hires in order to keep the
industry afloat it needs all the labor
it can get
30 of the UK's fishing crews are foreign
recruited through agencies from
countries such as Ghana and the
Philippines were almost the entire crew
of this vessel is from Roland berliance
here eight months a year because the
money's good lower salaries could drive
much needed workers elsewhere money in
here is really good really really good I
really appreciate the new learn the
people they treat us very good yeah for
this okay accommodation is okay
everything is very good industry leaders
are now urging the government to loosen
its rules to help resolve the labor
shortage including scrapping strict
English language requirements
the irony is the fishing industry was a
poster child for those advocating
leaving the EU but the promised boom
hasn't happened and the UK still doesn't
have many of the freedoms of other
Coastal States including EU member
France
fishermen of 35 years David Wilson feels
lied to yeah we were we were sold down a
river for brexit we were promised gold
and we've got coal
fishing joins construction on the
government's shortage occupation list
retail and Hospitality are lobbying hard
to be included too after losing huge
numbers of staff from the European Union
when the freedom to work in the UK ended
tacit recognition say many of these
fishermen of brexit's failure to make
Britain a better market for business
Neve Barker Al Jazeera brigson